qu'yves la capitale est encore en guerre
et ça se voit au barrage anti char et
aux sacs de sable mais elle achève sa
première semaine de tranquillité depuis
le début de la guerre un soupçon de
normalité dans l'air
cette tranquillité fait en sorte que les
trains en provenance de l'ouest et qui
arrive active ont d'abord beaucoup de
gens qui ont décidé de revenir chez eux
malgré les menaces russe persistantes
sur la capitale sur les presque 5
millions de personnes déplacées de
l'ukraine 1 million est déjà revenu le
flux s'est inversée
ce sont surtout des femmes et des
enfants qui reviennent c'est le cas de
caterina et ses filles souhaitent l'anah
et marina qui s'était réfugié à lviv se
sentiront tel en sécurité active
skillman à elles sont un peu peur mais
le désir de rentrer à la maison
l'emporter c'est la même chose pour
cette lan à
elle ne sait pas si elle sera en
sécurité mais elle rentre chez elle à
irbine
banlieue nord-est de qu'yves où ont eu
lieu les combats les plus féroces la
décision de rentrer chez soi à kiev la
capitale se comprend car elle était
plutôt épargné des attaques russes mais
dans les banlieues là où les forces
russes ont été stoppés de mauvaises
surprises attendent ceux qui reviennent
et les autorités essayent de décourager
les gens de le faire ir pin paie le prix
de la première grande victoire de
l'ukraine sur l'envahisseur russe des
ruines témoignent des combats acharnés
qui ont duré un mois les russes tentait
de contourner kiev par le sud ils ont
perdus faisant des centaines de victimes
certaines exécuté mais ils ont subi de
très lourdes pertes qu'yves était sauvé
spitz l'anah ekaterina ont été évacués
vers l'ouest dès le début des combats
elles viennent de revenir et se tiennent
devant l'hôtel de ville désemparée elle
nous ont conduits à leur appartement
dans cette maison qui semble
relativement intacte la cage d'escalier
tient le coup mais l'intérieur est un
désastre six personnes occuper
l'appartement à elles deux elles ont
trois enfants
toutes les fenêtres ont sauté des
morceaux de murs sont arrachés il ya des
débris partout les soldats russie y ont
même séjourné ils ont laissé des rations
militaires
elles ne peuvent que deviner ce qui
s'est passé c'est l'explosion du magasin
d'à côté qui a tout détruit
en face à l'immeuble lourdement
endommagées elles tiennent à nous
montrer le trou d'obus d'un char dans le
mur
et aussi la tombe improvisé d'un hommage
est mort pendant les combats
maintenant elles veulent demander de
l'aide à cet homme le maire dira pin
oleksandr marcoux chine il demande aux
exilés de ne pas revenir maintenant le
temps de trouver des logements
temporaires et de restaurer les services
l'eau ou l'électricité
mr n'a peur des certitudes car 50% de la
ville est détruite parce qu'elle a
résisté et qu'elle est devenue un champ
de bataille et lui un héros qui est
persuadé que l'ukraine va gagner la
guerre china mobile
parce que nous défendons notre pays nos
maisons nos familles les russes font
perdre jean michel leprince l'est du
canada ir pin ukraine